before we begin I want to say a little
prayer for our beloved rusty we'll miss
you little guy
and now lock yourselves in for the most
exciting film about pensions since
cocoon Mads Mikkelsen plays Duncan aka
the black kaiser assumed to be retiree
in the assassin community who just wants
to live out his days renting videos in
drinking away as sorrows you and me both
dude but things take a turn for the
worse when in order to save his failing
company hand cream enthusiast blood
seriously what the hell kind of name is
blood decides to kill off all the old
assassins so he doesn't have to pay
their pensions and if there's one thing
that pisses off old people the most it's
[ __ ] with their pensions and maybe
hip hop now Duncan must fend off a team
of younger sexier assassins and
seriously what's up with Cindy she is
like no skills except for eating pickles
and showing off her ass I guess that
does make her and assassin okay I'll
shut up we also have the best
performance from Vanessa Hudgens since
high school musical she plays Camille a
recluse who sucks at chopping wood and
will get into her more in a bit but back
to the beginning
Duncan is contracted by Vivienne to find
out who killed Michael the guy whose
boner we saw deflate in the introduction
but it's all a setup and Duncan learns
he's been backstabbed he's then tracked
by the second worst group of assassins
next to the Suicide Squad hahaha but
even though the hit went wrong the
assassins make it out with Camille and
Duncan is tricked by an old mentor where
he is tortured in the worst imaginable
way bagpipe music
in the beginning when Duncan is getting
his checkup and pear tart eand we learn
he has some shrapnel buried in his
abdomen
shrapnel that breaks off the night blood
uses to stab him and that he'll later
used to pick the lock and escape his
imprisonment he makes his escape through
a tunnel with one of the best and ultra
violent sequences in the film I mean
come on just look at this unsure of
where to go to and a young girl to save
he confides in an old lover jasmine who
hooks him up with laser guns with all
the assassins dead Duncan makes his way
to blood who fires on his own hitmen
Duncan's straight up just walks in and
the other hitmen rush past him and are
like he's upstairs he makes quick work
of blood throwing his decapitated head
out the window but here's where we get
to the real twist ending after saving
Camille and arriving back home in
Montana he finds her missing only paper
clippings about a nine-year-old girl
surviving a lone gunman attack and money
transfers scattered along the bed
throughout the entirety of the movie
Duncan has been plagued with a specific
event that has haunted him and here's
where it all comes together
Duncan was sent on an assassination
mission based on wrong information the
people in that car shouldn't have died
so every year Duncan anonymously
transfers $200,000 to Camille as a way
of redemption
Camille even calls him out on it saying
you can't pay for your own salvation and
Duncan knows it's true he closes his
eyes and tells her not to think just
pull the trigger he's willing to own up
to his past and get what's coming to him
after all he's been drinking himself
silly every night haunted by that past
the irony isn't lost here either that
Camille is using the same gun Duncan got
her as a present and taught her how to
shoot with but the past also haunts
Camille in the end she gives the most
emotional monologue in the entire film
and we learn why she flinches every time
a loud noise happens like here in the
convenience store and here at the diner
the loud noises remind her of that
fateful day when she was 9 in the end
Camille chooses not to kill Duncan a man
who is willing to pay the ultimate
sacrifice for what he has done this is a
man who is truly remorseful instead
Camille asks who ordered the hit as were
off Duncan and Camille steering into the
vast Montana wilderness perhaps to work
together and take vengeance on the
person who so ruined their lives in the
end Poehler is the story about law
and redemption Kamiya loses her family
and swears vengeance but is redeemed
when she learns that vengeance won't
bring them back
Duncan redeems himself when he puts his
life on the line not only to save
Camille but when he's confronted with
the past and accepts his fate the ending
is one of new beginnings for these two
and for Netflix the beginning of a
potential sequel but one thing this film
does moderately well is create empathy
for our protagonists which is no small
feat considering this is a man whose job
is to kill others the writer does this
in a number of ways first by showing us
he likes animals even buying a book to
learn how to care for them chopping
Camille's would anonymously and even
getting her a present it's what every
girl wants but I'll never forgive you
for rusty I hope you enjoy this video
what do you think of these more light
type reviews what movies or TV shows do
you want me to do next as always make
sure to leave a comment like and
subscribe I have more videos coming up
in their rise in and until next time
remember daddy loves you very much